but I get it I keep getting messages
from people saying I really like what
you're doing
I can't tweet about it honestly I had
one the other day from quite a prominent
actor say I really really like I saw the
show actually said I really liked the
tiny show I can't tweet about it cuz I
can't be bothered with the back I should
I'm gonna face the back - so he's
sympathize with that why should that but
you know why should there be a backlash
for expressing an opinion but she Brigid
mentions in the article which is the the
best way I've seen to put it that people
aren't voting out of habit or for their
own interests it's now a comment on your
personal I don't like and worth quite so
let's take the brexit vote whether the
media reduced it to leave equals bad
remain equals good not just the media
but sort of the people in this not very
middle class circle that that's how they
reduced it leave equals racist remain
equals compassionate yeah and non racist
okay it's a lie that everyone bought
into it's pathetic and it's the left
well it's exactly it's that reductive
thing I'm reducing actually a very
complicated new and specifically to an
easy shortcut you know why do you think
that people are doing that at the moment
why are people reducing down difficult
discussions to these real tweet lengths
there's a good psychological reason
there's a think of the cognitive misers
and model which means that you you
instinctively try and find the easiest
to train of thought your mind that
you're you'll always go for the easiest
it actually takes a bit of effort to
think about things if if you've got this
situation for instance with the brakes
of oh and you can just say well that's
how it's good in that size evil well it
sees it's an easy choice to make
otherwise you have to start
understanding the issues there's a whole
lot harder I get that and yeah it
started something a lot happen with
Trump it's happening now with with with
Boris Johnson so there's gonna be it's
the same thing against are you a good
person and this is why the polls never
work anymore this is why no one
predicted Trump no one predicted brexit
it never works because people have their
opinions they have they have two sets of
opinions but they're they've got the
opinions that they actually feel and
they've got the opinions that they know
they can express in public
right and those two are no longer the
same it used to be the case that they
were the same I remember talking to an
old trade unionist about this and saying
that you know we used to be able to talk
to like some of the miners and
everything about and they would be
really homophobic they'd say like you
know they hate [ __ ] and all this oil
didn't use [ __ ] that's it queers back
then with maggots but you know but they
were right on all these other issues and
rather than bulk on that and say or
whether you're obviously a fascist I
won't talk to you about anything this
guy was saying what I'd say to them is
well okay you're right about these
social issues and these economic issues
so can we now talk about your issues
about sexuality and and then it became a
discussion and then people change their
minds and that was that's a great thing
to happen right but now if say for
instance you've got one opinion that is
not acceptable say you are anti-abortion
right so that for many leftists is like
one of the the sins Cardinals Fawcett
right so if you're in that then then
suddenly we right off you we write you
off completely yeah
so even if we agree on other things it
doesn't matter anymore you're now the
bad person you're now an evil person
it's really unsophisticated yeah and
it's perfect this is why I end up
agreeing with people who on the whole I
can't I don't agree with on anything and
for instance um let's take the free
speech question you know so I am NOT a
nationalist I would never vote you kid
or in the basis there's a Nationalist
Party and I'm not nationalist so
fundamentally I don't have anything in
common with them but they're right about
free speech right so that they recognize
that there's a problem with free speech
the Labour Party in the Tory Party are
both against free speech both of them
are for hate speech laws for instance
the Labour Party want to push more press
regulation if at all possible Theresa
May is one of the worst when it comes to
free speech I mean she she since her she
denied Tyler the Creator and entrance to
the UK on the basis of a rat pink done
right which is great cuz then he did an
auntie Theresa my rap which sounds
really surreal people forget about that
but I did that did actually happen I
didn't dream so when you've got the two
major parties of anti-free speech you've
got to be able to say this other party
that I have nothing in common with that
actually I can't really stand i I am
they are right about that but you say
that and then also how your you kid
sport
no not I'm vote like no this tiny little
sliver they're correct about love what
they're saying and no one gets their own
principles right so my principle is
either right or it's wrong okay so you
you should be able to say I don't
approve of anything that person says or
does but on that they're right because
they don't own the principle there's no
more room for nuance no limit in
discussions now
[Music]